ليس من السهل على هؤلاء العوده الى
منازلهم ولا من السهل عليهم التغلب على
قسوه العيش في المخيم فهذه الاسر التي
هجرت منازلها قبل اعوام بسلاح الميليشيات
من الكدح غربا تصارع اليوم الفقر بالتسول
بحثا عن ما يسد رقما
بسبب البرد
هذا الذي نعاني منه هذه الايام والاطفال
يعانون من الامنيات والامراض بسبب الصقور
والزكام
لا كوثر ولا مالح ولا معنا اي حاجه ناسها
اسحب منها البئر
عايشين يعني على حاجه كره
الضروره اللي عملنا نحضر نحنا
ملابس توقيهم برد الشتاء مضطر عائلتهم الى
عدم ارسالهم للمدارس والمنظمات الانسانيه
لا تلبي احتياجاتهم الاساسيه
يعني ايام البرد ما معناش تيتان نروح
المدرسه
في هذه السنه بالذات همم قلت الدعم قلت
المنظمات التي تحضر اليهم لدعمهم
لمساندتهم ولدهم يعانون من مشاكل كبيره
حتى يعانون في قضايا الامراض الامراض
التيتهم في تعز والساحل الغربي يعانون من
افتقارهم للغذاء والماء والدواء وهو امر
فاقم من معاناتهم في المخيمات السعيد
العربيه تعز